welcome to mad flavors world [ __ ]
Joey Coco Diaz here fresh mint flavors
world at LAX with my man Duncan Trussell
on our way to Kennedy Airport for the
UFC where's my man doesn't trust me
there he is over there trying to get
some stuff
who is beauty ready look at this beauty
right here don't [ __ ] none cat who
knows what's going on you don't say
there's Duncan trust havoc they're mad
flavor were on our way to New York I was
showing it Duncan Trussell so here we go
again things are bad all over you want
me to tell you what our [ __ ] is wrong
with society look at this line right
here for Starbucks you see that
Starbucks coffee liquor as sheep right
there you see that they're on line
waiting for [ __ ] coffee only in this
country has that become sheep you don't
saying well it became a sheep that's
what we're becoming
forget about sheep and sheep back stay
black
mad flavor Duncan Trussell on the flight
to New York you commiserating ready a
blast-off here
smoking [ __ ] phony cigarettes like
Zsa Zsa Gabor's boyfriend New York City
[ __ ] and beautiful hot dog right there
that's like nine thousand [ __ ] points
your [ __ ] alright the one in your in
New York you got to do what you got to
do [ __ ]
that's the main man right there the hot
dog man we're here mad flavors world
stay black at the famous spots by the
[ __ ] steakhouse right go on the floor
right there was right there lay right
down the floor bleeding from his [ __ ]
eyeballs [ __ ] and his guide Tommy
Bilotti was laying right next to the
ghost to here and it's all over math
flavor as well in New York City with
Duncan grow in the whole [ __ ] daily
I'm saying Steve black [ __ ] mad
flavors well New York City
you made the cut with the geese and [ __ ]
North Bergen
we got geese with a little family look
at them little four little [ __ ]
run your flock stay black beautiful wife
well my man Harry one garden is [ __ ]
favorite tweets these temptations drives
them crazy stuff that's the [ __ ] misc
mix-up with that which guy like three
different barbeque breeds but Harry's
gardening like the Rock of Gibraltar
just in case E soup beds try to come up
because I'm getting some of those treats
but Harry's like no you ain't [ __ ]
it ain't happening not on my clock see
mad flavors world ain't about mad flavor
it's about what I deal with it now this
[ __ ] down and make him believe
you don't know what time it is but he
really wants those [ __ ] treats but
Harry's like I don't think so not a
little friendly video from your friends
at temptations tree Harry say hello to
these [ __ ] we stay black you're
looking at that bitch's headlining Joey
Diaz the Miami improv it was a beautiful
[ __ ] weekend mad flavors world Miami
if you snooze you lose [ __ ] this is
my man Carlos Perez from North Bergen
New Jersey I grew up with one of my
closest friends we grew up down on 38th
Street I want a good Coco Diaz story
Carlos not the TAC Kristen we still on
for the city and play three-card Monte
in eighth grade not when we [ __ ] lie
when you click the car a Chevy stolen
broke the glass I need a good story hit
Collin longs to get together on Sundays
and do THC crystal for $10 and his
freshman year hang out hang out in the
park this show sir thank you sir how
about the night that we robbed like 25
cars in one night that's right from but
I get that but I thought one time as uh
out of our heads night 25 [ __ ] car
boo and we drove them off the [ __ ]
thing right we flip them over flip them
over and a half of them we are torch 25
[ __ ] cars that's what happens when
you piss me off Bergen kids are right
there Carlos Brack there's one of my
dearest friends and we've known each
other since 75 we grew up together
giving that Terrace
this guy's got you'd always like her
mother Black Sabbath uh
Hey did I really get what what is it was
an eight-track what was it it was a
paranoid yeah
paranoid on fear cuz I think I made
copies very but I was blown the [ __ ]
away with my main man Martin Perez we've
known each other
[ __ ] fifth grade McKinley is Ricky
boom-boom Cruz my brother this is Carlos
is something a little nephew I don't
even know I had this [ __ ] che guevara
lookin [ __ ] over here's my
nephew my man Carlos Perez Rainey my
brother look at him oh you from Kuala my
beautiful wife my beautiful wife that's
my little brother from the burden that's
mrs. Perez I've known over 80 years -
[ __ ] osmosis and that's a soccer
player example over here she's not from
North Bergen but [ __ ] it she's
honourable you know I'm saying that's my
girl game by the math flavors world with
the North Bergen crew say hello
[ __ ] without a Joey that's it
stay black [ __ ]
check them out this [ __ ]
well I'm skinny Finney what up what up
say hello that's right say hello say
hello to people that's right that's
right
so which little [ __ ] is going on but
it's right that's my man skinny thing
we're back [ __ ] mad flavors world
you'll love the documentary